il a été avec elle non j'ai pas été j'ai
rencontré une fois arrêté un jour on dit
oui oui oui oui j'ai couché avec elle
oui j'ai couché avec elle mais je vous
rappelle plus comment elle s'appelle toi
donc ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire
mais je m'en bas à part moi en fait
avant moi tu as tes qualités mannequins
non tu as été avec une hifi normal quoi
le prochain aura là bas une fille
comment une fille normale parce que tu
te crois que norman toi je suis normal
j'ai pas normal du louvre si mais si tu
vois tu m'attends à rien et coûte
j'étais plus jeune j'étais un peu con
j'avais envie de me mettre avec défi
belle parce que ça me rassure et je me
dis voilà servis sur gallas et les
voitures moi c'était déjà là voilà c'est
tout dire on fait vite plutôt regarde
écoute moi je préfère un film comme toi
oui je connais les fennecs une
samaritaine entière de un bon ouais